ناس وهذه النسبه المشاركه ضئيله وهذهله
جدا فقط
للمفارقه تعد من ادنى نسب مشاركه عبر
العالم منذ الحرب العالميه اساميك ليس فقط
في تاريخ تونس يعني حتى عندما كنت هناك
بعض التونسيين يتحدثون الي يقولون همم
نسبه مشاركه اقل من انتخابات في هيئه مثلا
واحنا نعلم بان تونس خاصه منذ الثوره كانت
تعرف زخاما سياسيا كبيرا وجاءت هذه
الانتخابات لتقطع ان صح- تعبير مشاهد تونس
خلال العشر سنوات الاخيره همم ما لاحظناها
في الحقيقه عزيزه منذ اللحظه التي وصلت
فيها هي غياب التام لمظاهر انتخابات نحن
متعودون هنا مثلا في فرنسا عندما تكون
هناك انتخابات رئاسيه وحتى تشريعيه نشهد
الزخم الانتخابيه حملات ملصقات مرشحين هذا
كان غائبا تماما عندما كنت اتجول فيه
الشوارع كنت ابحث عن صوره لاي مرشح لاي
علامه ل- عمليا انتخابيه لا تقام قريبا لا
شيء من كل هذا حتى المواطنين اتذكر جيدا
سائق التكسي الذي همم نقلني من المطار الى
الفندق تحدثت معه عن العمليه السياسيه
تعرفين عزيزه سائقي التاكسي هم المحرار
بالنسبه لاين اي مشهد سياسي في اي دوله
قال لي انا بالنسبه لي هذه الانتخابات
ليست موجوده لم ارى اي مرشح جاء تحدث الي
لم اقرا برامج لم احس بان هناك حمله همم
قلت لك في همم نقل مباشر امسي التونسيون
يقولون عن اي انتخابات
وهذا شاهدناه في مراكز الاقتراع بصراحه
صحفيون الذين اتوا لتغطيه الانتخابات كان
عددهم اكبر من الناخبين طب ما المنتظر
دنيا يعني ما تدعيات هذا هذا المشهد على
المرحله المقبله اليوم قصه سعيده تتحدث عن
الدوره الثانيه في مارس اضرار التي يطرح
لماذا ننتظر حتى مارس ادار يعني ما
المنتظر من هذه الانتخابات هي المشكله
التي تطرحها المعارضه التي يتحدث عنها
الشعب التونسي ايضا هي ما مدى مشروعيه او
شرعيه هذه الانتخابات بهذه النسبه
المتدنيه يعني عندما ننظر الى الارقام
تسعه ملايين ناخذ كانوا اا منتظرون 11%
فقط صوتوا مليون ناخب وفق الهيئه العليا
المستقله للانتخابات هل يمثل هذا صوت
التونسيين بشكل الكافي قيس سعيد كما ذكرت
قبل قليل قال لا يجب التوقف عند نسبه
التمثيليه لكن في اي ديموقراطيه هذه
النسبه مهمه جدا وكنا ننتظر هذه الكلمه هل
سيستخلص الرئيس التونسيه العبره الدرس من
همم ما حصل مما تقول عنه المعارضه بانه
فشل حتى يتحدى العامه التونسي للشغل القلب
بان ما حدث هو دليل على فشل الاداره
الحاليه في تسيير امور البلاد لكن السؤال
مطروح واا لديك حق في طرحه همم الدوره
ثانيه يعني لماذا ننتظر حتى همم السنه
المقبله ممكن شهر مارس الحمله لدوله ثانيه
ستنتق- ستنطلق في ال 20 من يناير
علم الدوله الاولى كيف تدار الامور هل
للبرلمان اليوم دور في العمليه السياسيه
خاصه هناك ازمه ثقه بين الشعب وبين
الاحزاب السياسيه اذا هذا الانسداد يعني
هل من اي افق هل من اي امل يلوح في الافق
لهذه الحلقه او هذه بدايه بالنسبه للدوره
الثانيه والرئيس قلبي ان سننتظر الجوله
الثانيه همم
حقيقه المشاركه من عدمها السؤال المطروح
فعلا هو هل سيذهب النابون همم الى دوله
ثانيه في ظل ما حدث في الدوله الاولى ممكن
ان نتصور ان يكون هناك عزوفا اكبر بالتالي
البرلمان اي شرع- اي شرعيه له اي تمثيليه
له في اطار اصلا سلطات محدوده اعطيت هذا
البرلمان في الدستور الجديد الدستور الذي
طرح للمصادق عليه في الخامس والعشرين من
يوليو
بعض التونسيين عندما تحدثنا اليهم قالوا
لنا ما همم الضروره او ما الحاجه الى
برلمان اصلا همم فاقد الصلاحيه فان كان
فاقد الصلاحيه اساسا بموجب الدستور وفاقد
الشرعيه بموجب نسبه المشاركه المتدنجه ما
الحاجه لبرلمان اصلا هناك ايضا تونسيين
يقولون نحن معاشناه مع النظام البرلماني
ومن المناوشات التي شهدناها داخل تحت قبه
الشعب لا نريد ان نرى هذا مره ثانيه ربما
هذا ايضا سبب في عزوف الناخبين عن التصويت
في هذه الانتخابات التشريعيه بالنهايه
بالنهايه سننتظر همم الحمله همم الدوره
الثانيه من الانتخابات سننتظر ايضا الموقف
الشركاء الدوريتين هذا مهم جدا بالنسبه
للمستقبل تونس عزيزه تونس تفاوض على قرض
من صندوق النقد الدولي حتى الان لا شيء
مضمون لا شيء محدد في هذه النقطه همم
تفعل فرنسي همم
المتحده
وسنرى كيف نسبه التضخم ترتفع ما يقال في
تونس ان نسبه التضخم اعلى من نسبه
المشاركه في الانتخابات التشريعيه ههه
شكرا جزيلا لك الدنيا نورت شكرا عزيز اريد
ان اقول هذا هذه الجمله ولكن قلتيها جزيلا
لكن يا نور